find the amount of compound interest
earned on seven thousand dollars
invested at 10 per annum for three years
okay let's start
you start by writing this sucker down do
it okay write it down right away
okay so the amount equals
principal times one plus the rate
to this power okay there you go
now once you've got this down you read
in the question what are they going to
be the parts that you fit into this okay
so which one's the principle out of the
numbers they give you which ones are the
principles
it's the seven thousand exactly right so
there's my seven thousand out the front
instead of p
which one are you doing number one
and in the brackets we've got one plus
now i want the rate what's the rate
uh have a look sorry it's about three
years
ten percent per annum for three years
the rate's going to be the percentage
one okay because the three years is how
long it's in there
okay so i want 10 but i want it as a
decimal like this what's ten percent
less more than one point one isn't it
yeah good
i've got one plus there's the rate
that's ten percent
you happy with that is that okay yeah
what's the last piece
n which is how many years which is three
inches
there you go okay now just before i um
chuck that in my calculator i'll just
tidy it up
slightly i might as well put these two
together the one
and the zero point one so i'll just do
this
like that okay so you get your
calculator out and you do it
seven thousand times
now luckily if you even have a cubed
cubed button on your calculator
you don't need to do power and then
three but it doesn't matter which one
you do and we get nine thousand
three hundred and seventeen and zero
cents
ta-da